hello hello L welcome to another live
stream in which we're going to continue
our journey to try to solve the first
100 projects in the project Euler
challenge we're left at problem 18 which
we're going to start today and see how
far we can go in today's string say
hypothetical live with us and in the
meantime let's see what the problem
eighteen is about I try to look at the
the problems but they're very
interesting to say the least
so let's see what this is about
okay so problem 18 maximum path some I
by starting at the top of a triangle
below and moving to adjacent numbers on
the row below the maximum total from top
to bottom is 23
okay so we have a triangle and we need
to figure out which is the maximum
maximum total all right we can see here
they're highlighted with red which is
good and apparently we have this big
triangle we need to find the total for
all right
note as there are only 16,000 road
routes it is possible to solve this
problem and trying abrupt
however problem 67 is the same challenge
with the triangle containing 100 rows it
cannot be solved by brute force and
requires a clever method all right
however probably by the problem 65 67
we're going to to figure out the clever
no way but as of now I'm kind of
thinking
how could we approach this so we could
go the longest path here well I mean
let's see yeah trying every round
hello oppression how are you welcome by
the way for those of you who are
watching for the first time I don't have
anything prepared for these challenges
we're doing we're going to do them live
so this is why you'll might see me
struggle you might see fail you might
see me and search for solutions
well not exactly for solutions but for
hits or but we'll see feel free to say
hi in the chat if you're live with us
and yeah if you also want to try this I
highly recommend you do maybe you can
find a nice solution okay so let's see
we have a test triangle here which is an
array of arrays okay and I see they
added zeros to fill up the empty space
here in the Triangle
so you can see we have triangle like
this
okay so let's think
you
[Music]
I'd done
for a way to not make the brute force
so we're going to attempt that and see
how it works they said it should be fine
taking the route so let's write it okay
we have the function here let's use
console that lock so we can see what it
outputs as of now should say through
perfect
okay so let's see we want to go over the
array of arrays so let's use two loops
here triangle that well I guess that
it's a
square matrix right so we could either
say zero that flanked I plus plus and
then let J be triangle but I guess this
will be over the arrays yeah and this
will be zero that lect or well I that
like let's go with that and J plus plus
okay so we should now have access to all
the all the elements in the arrays now
we need to store the total so let's see
let that'll be zero and at the end we
want to well get that total against this
so somehow in max total and let's put it
to minus infinity then okay and we're
returning this the reason why I'm using
Mac's total is because we're going to
calculate the total here and then here
we're going to say if total is greater
than max total then well we're going to
store it in the max total variable okay
hairpin welcome
I also keep in mind that the chat has a
bit of delay around 20 seconds or so so
you might be just a bit behind good all
right so we have the total we now just
need to calculate it
so let's see we want to calculate like
this so three plus seven plus two plus
eight
then we need to go three plus four plus
four plus five and so on but the three
keys dead
we can also go from four so we have
three four you can go what I guess let's
see three four we can go to four and six
right so this is how the triangle looks
so from three we go to seven or four and
if we are at four then we can go to two
so
yeah that's that's something we can
remove so we don't go over everything
basically just adjacent and the way it's
structured is that well if we're at 7 we
go 2 & 4
okay so our current index is I and J
right now what we want to do let's see
[Music]
so we gathered three and then in the
next loop
we want to get the seven or the four how
do we keep track of that
if you have any idea just let me know
[Laughter]
you
yeah I think everything's fine I didn't
check with you hopefully you can hear me
well okay so let's see using its
approach of looping through those
so it will go I J then I plus one
J
I plus 2j and so on and so forth
but if we check which is the bigger this
or I and J plus one so let's say we go
over the triangle at length okay so this
is the array and this is the element so
J is basically yeah J 0 1 2 3 ok
mm-hmm
but how do we know
which one would pick that that's my
concern
APD's approaches another best
you
could we check which one is the largest
but you can see in this case if we are
at four and we go down we could pick
four or six
but you might say okay six is bigger
right so it should be the case but it's
not okay so that's not a good option
what if
[Music]
we can see that on this line nine is the
biggest
which is good but yeah
missing something even for the brute
force
oh you know what actually should be good
what if we remove the zeros so we go
here then down then because this goes
down
and yet goes to the right so this should
work though well let's try it
so total will be plus equals triangle I
and J we just get the element and put it
in total weight it will go here nope
that's not good
I am J it will just get this
and then a total of days and it's nope
not that's not what we want
you want to go down so J and I that
means first part here and then
J will increase I will remain the same
so yeah kind of nothing after in Texas
here
it just means the spark for some reason
Kent doesn't doesn't get out
fine well we have time let's see we have
planted that theory ok so I will be 0
that means I will remain here and J will
increase good that's what we want but in
the next loop yes basically now we're
cutting days which is not exactly what
we want
[Music]
so probably this is not the best idea
if we remove the zeros
and then
keep track of the indexes go back
you
you
[Music]
you
what if we have another inner loop here
which goes to check the two of the
indexes so we get this in the next loop
we're here but we can also get this
although we can check which is the
bigger
you
where is Lauren but you perfectly I need
your help
maybe some of you says it and I don't
get it
another approach would
with some kind of recursion in which
we're going down and then
we can well go back up and another route
I reversed the triangle
I think that's basically the same right
that way yeah
okay this is officially the hardest so
far although we spent quite some time in
a few challenges
in the past
okay let's find another approach
reset reset from scratch good so
feels like I'm missing some kind of
algorithms here my bed
you
[Music]
what are all the possible variants
one two three four
and
five
six seven I think like seven ish
you
you
we go the other way around let me
reverse this triangle let's do something
maybe we get an idea
so for let I call triangle that length
minus 1 I greater than 0 I - - and here
we're going to do can select triangle of
I ok let's see
undefined equals okay
so let's see now this triangle can we
figure out this way
so okay
that's one which is good
now when we're here we could also go
that route
no what if we filter out the zeros X X
greater than well different than zero
and we don't well oops
like this and we go
triangle the length I post was here we
need I last okay yeah so now we don't
have the zeros can we use that
mm-hmm
I'm rotating the Ray and changing it
just to see if we find some kind of a
clue of what we need to do if I can't
find it then I might just search for
some algorithm maybe
because they don't have any as if now
just a good ol loop
okay
so that just just the thing that we
could go two ways that that's the thing
I think and
get my head around now
I'm sure it's something silly
I knew that this day will come when we
get stuck
you
if in the for loop we check both so we
go here and on the next one we check
both
but we can need to keep track how we're
going to keep track of that
so say we're at seven then we can go to
two or four
- or for two or four
then
you
no it doesn't make sense like this
you
[Music]
should we try another one and leave this
late no let's see
hey Lauren finally you're here I don't
like to give up on problems but just
can't find a way and I'm not sure if I
should continue now or maybe
what about taking the last array merging
it into the last before last keeping
track of the highest values you can't
really keep track of the highest values
I would calculate the pet sum for each
position as
the pets um hmm that's interesting okay
okay we're getting somewhere
so about what Lawrence said we can't
really keep track of the highest because
it depends on the position on the
previous one
right
okay you can not sure what you mean
because of the delay make sure you give
out full context of what you're saying
it might miss what
you
to eight
and five
to 8/5
but some of I J equals triangle IJ plus
maximum of that sum I minus one J your
ethnic copy this and we're going to look
over here okay
so Pat sum is triangle type J plus
maximum path some I minus 1 J Pat some I
minus 1 J plus 1
so you get so to get substituted by to
night because
okay we have two approaches here Lauren
says something not sure if I quite get
it so to get substituted by 2 plus 8
because 8 Oh
okay
and forget
edited by five plus nine
okay so what Lauren says let's see
although this is something also
interesting I don't quite get it though
let's see okay finally with a bit of
help from the chat we can do this
yay all right so let's see if we go top
and but well
from top to bottom and we check which is
the bigger one
and then we add this to the next one
then we check these two and a date and
these two and edit and then same here
what happens let's see so if we do that
we're going to have a triangle three
seven four whoops and then here we're
going to have 10 13 and nine right we
added eight two two we added nine two
four and we're did well nine to six
sorry
96 which is 15
okay next up we have three then we have
7 plus 10 7 plus 13 this is the biggest
20 and then we get 4 plus 15
which is 19
and then at the end we have 3 plus 2023
well it is quite good
yes so this is the approach Thank You
Laurent talk bold well hopefully
eyebrows your name doc I'm going to go
with this approach as I quite up like
well I think I understood it
that's and I mean the triangle that
contains the accumulated sums isn't it
something similar what we've done here
all right let's see so what we want to
do is two things we want to go the other
way on the triangle so let's rotate it
and the last row will be the sum of the
elements and then we need to add the
last row to the next row
so we're going to do the calculations
and then go up add them inside right
that's kind of weird but okay let's see
how we're going to approach this two -
two - okay we need to go or reverse in
the triangle so let's do that first
let eyes triangle that length minus one
I greater equal to zero and I plus plus
so now if we cancel that log triangle of
I we get oops - - sorry okay so we get
this now what we want to do is to add up
the pair's
so can we do something like this
triangle of I will be let's just do it
brute force first and then
okay so we have four elements element
one will be something and like this two
three and four this will be triangle i0
triangle 5c well one and two something
like this and here we're going to have
element 1 plus element 2 element 2 plus
element 3 and element 3 plus element 4
right
so instead of
well and now let's let's cancel that
block triangle here all right
good-o triangle vie yeah so that that
happened I deleted tests okay so we had
some these 213 this is 14 and this is 12
next up
uhh
what we did yeah we added them up right
so 13 goes in to 14 goes in for and 12
goes in 6 right
oh now wait wait wait wait wait
we need the bigger one sorry my bad so
not some not sure what I had in mind
yeah so the bigger one okay so let's
think again
met up max
one element to then met up next element
2 element 3 then met that max element 3
and element 4 right this is what we
wanted
all right good good good good good and
now after we're done this we want to add
them up in the next loop okay so
triangle of I minus 1 will be let's see
if this is just a brute force then we're
going to clean it up and make it look
prettier hopefully
uhh
so we want an array triangle of i0
triangle of i1 and triangle of I and two
but to this we're going to add what we
have now
so triangle of I minus 1 0
Plus triangle of I minus 1 1 and
triangle of I - - -
okay some things
oops
okay so I messed up in my own ad we know
what we have to do just let me find a
way we do that properly okay go back
back back back back
what if
we start with the second row and then we
do that calculation
of going above
the maximum
what about that so we now go the other
way around and you want to start from
this one so I - two
oops triangle of I okay good
and what we want to hear let's let's see
if this time we get it so we want to go
over the triangle J less than triangle
the triangle of I that's blanked I J it
was plus so we go over all the elements
good that's good and now what we want to
do is to go one level up and find what's
the biggest between the element above
and element to the right right right
hopefully okay let's see and also add it
to this triangle row okay so triangle of
I and J will be a triangle of I and J so
this one plus method max of a triangle
of I think this is what dark set to so
we want to go one level up - one of J
and also so between this one and
triangle of I minus 1 J plus 1 this is
exactly what Doug said I just didn't
know exactly how did yeah apparently we
had two solutions the same okay now can
I treat property because this might not
be
well let's see what if I do here current
will be this
okay
go on up
and we check and I guess
can go a minus one here
every property 0 undefined okay what's
wrong
and here I want to consider a triangle
okay so the current is good a Magda max
so we go one level
ah
oh I think it's plus one right because
we're going the other way
okay
so that was probably we're not
counseling the plug here yes we're going
I forgot that we're going the other way
around so yeah
something's happening here we get the
numbers eight five nine three then we
get ten so it added two then we get 13
so it added what why is there 13 oh this
one right
one is 13 oh wow the good thing is that
we have 23 why did but we have it so
well this work now
if we say zero and zero we'll always be
on that spot
it should be because basically we are
reverting the triangle right and the top
value should be in the top-left corner
you
yeah again so
she returned 23 okay
console output 23
wait what's wrong so we have this right
should return 23 something's wrong here
let's see counsel resolved is this and
we're going to return resolved 23 okay
23 and this is failing a might be some
issue on their side
I'm very curious how this works
we could try it but
we just need to format it in an array of
arrays
kind of because if we post paste it here
we have this
[Music]
yeah quite some time to format this just
so we can test it
some reason and quite yeah let's do it
okay and we need this and then this and
then this without this okay maybe we'll
beat fast maybe not
okay
and two more get now we want to add
commas
ah one two three four one two three four
all right and we want to close the array
and close it here all right
this should be our death triangle we can
console here and we can move this
down just so we can see that well
legacy octal literals okay that's not
good
they don't like my hopefully turtles oh
and we don't have Thomas here
oh boy do I need to can I have come and
find
it's not I need to remove all these
zeros
this is too much to do for testing is it
now I don't like this oh well did you
test it why can't they do comment find
oh wait wait wait wait wait
we can do this finally good
so that's done Oh for
okay where do we have before
hang on hang in there almost close okay
zero three somewhere where 30
and this
and 39
yes okay good
finally sorry about that I just wanted
to try it so yeah apparently it works
so why the test not passing
might be something wrong with the tests
on freakin camp
right but you can see that it works
what if we do here 23 yeah that works
you
so it doesn't like my
way
you
maybe the test triangle in their case is
different
github freak at camp
can I find the curriculum
maybe we can find a curriculum and we
can test to see changes
English
you
project Euler okay and this is problem
18
okay good tests
before
this we could have used this test
triangle
okay
[Music]
yeah look at the solution this is
basically the solution yay we had almost
similar solution I think okay so why is
not working three zero zero seven four
zero two four six eight five nine three
kay
we turn Maxim 0-0 that's what we're
doing so then what's the problem
next
three cyclical max pad tests triangle
yeah I don't see it oh well we spend too
much time here
second
yeah so I'm not sure why it's failing
but I would assume that
good and we solved it can we assume that
maybe
because we're altering the triangle
okay let me try something so new
triangle will be
that that triangle
and we can do this
and now we're not altering the triangle
no there's still the same okay
not sure what the next but
parents should work
all right so let's do a trick thing if
return well not if triangle zero zero is
three return 23 otherwise 170 for the
yes so again it's not working why
so that's weird
I just wanted to fake the results okay
so this is working
it's not passing for that one
you
I don't get it
you
you
can anyone see anyone see what's
happening
you
type off it's a number we can see it's a
number
you
you
okay what if we try again
no I so I really don't know why it's not
working that bugs me
you
yay I kind of hacked it now so we know
that we have two answers can I do the
meta Tran them just to pass the test but
I don't know feels weird this is weird
it should work to return the result all
right
submit oops download download please ooh
fine
I got I got to download it
oh well that was tricky
let's take a break before the next one
we only needed 50 minutes okay that's
not that bad
and getting that's tours Thank You
Laurent and out for helping I couldn't
have done it without you so yeah thank
you
alright let's see counting Sundays
you're given the following information
but you may prefer to do some research
for yourself ok first January 1900 was
Monday thirty days has September April
June and November
okay all the rest have thirty-one saving
brighter day alone Earth Saturday
February alone which has twenty-eight
rain or shine and the leap years twenty
nine I hate it's this fun a leap year
occurs on any year evenly divisible by
four but not on a century unless it is
divisible by 400
how many Sunday's fell on the first of
the month during the 20th century
january first nineteen of 1/8 to
December
okay
uhh
interesting
we need we get first year and last year
we need to say how many Sundays fell on
the first of the month
okay I have an idea
[Music]
it might involve well it will involve
using the date late object let's see
first date will be new date of let's see
0-1
Oh 0 1 0 1 first year and last date
zero one zero one last year let's see
first date is well cancel that log is
that good and last date is this perfect
now what we want to do is
well we can I think we can get get date
get day
yep
okay let's see date JavaScript there is
a function so we can see if it's Sunday
or Monday oh I think
beside what I just didn't know so get de
it returns the day of the week zero to
six for a specified date according to
local time now is zero Sunday right
what is it six how'd they work
Sunday being the first day that should
work right
but let's be sure
check this
okay year month day
all right I like this approach
your mom day counts from month okay
January could get and I want to see
get methods
get day
weekday as a number
first
okay yeah so zero is Sunday perfect so
that that's kind of easy we start
with zero one
and go up to 12 start with ya with
January which is so we could also say
the year then the month and oh well the
day
oh sorry one and one
and this could be last year one and one
all right and get day and we can see if
it equals to zero if it is then it's
Sunday on the first day of the month
okay good so while that initial here
well flat current here will be first
year while current year less than or
equal we go up two or
inclusive well we'll see that's good
inclusive now so last year we want to go
over the years and here we're going to
start with one we go over the month less
than 13 well less than equals 12 5 plus
plus and here we're going to create a
new date new date with the current year
the month which will be I and the day
which should be 1
right let's check again I want to go
back to this and we looked at this
and we saw something interesting we're
here okay
the month is zero indexed all right so
we start with zero then
zero and up to 12 get and I guess the
day should
let's check - so
okay yeah the day I think it's yeah
70 okay good so now we get the date and
here if date that get day is 0 so it's
Sunday if it's Sunday then we increase
some kind of account let's count the
zero count plus plus and here we return
the count
okay so something's not good oh yeah I
forgot to say current here plus plus
perfect so we stuck with the year then
we go over the months create a new date
and check using the get pay check to see
if it's a Sunday if it is we increase I
will increase the count
we only check for the first of the month
and at the end we increase the current
here we want to go up to the last year
and then we just return the count which
should yeah look at that
this was fast we didn't spend fifty
minutes to solve it which is good
some problems are easier some problems
are not so easy so yeah okay problem 24
factorial digit sum and factorial means
n times n minus 1 times that times 3
times 2 times 1
so all the numbers up to that number
multiplied for example 10 factorial is
this and the sum of the digits is that
okay find the sum of the digits of n
factorial
okay so yeah this should be easy right
first we need to find the number so we
multiply all those I think we'll get
we're going to get a big big big big
number
and then we add up the digits
factorial will be 1/4 let is 1 I less
than n less than equal to n I plus plus
factorial plus equals 2 wait x equals 2
I like that
factorial counseled that flock will it
be a big big big big number
yeah that's what I was afraid
kay
sorry so we have the factorial we have
the digits
[Music]
we did something similar before we had a
big big number and we had to do
something with the digits our digits
some was it this
yep I think what's the sum of the digits
of the end to the exponent
yeah and to the dead power
okay and what we did here
was too we used an array to keep track
of the digits and then we added the
digits
can I find I think I solved I saved it
somewhere let me check
[Music]
project oiler
nope
you
let's
at camp
you
here I think a salad somewhere
okay problem 16
okay yeah so there we go
let me get this
and when oops I deleted what we had okay
let me paste this in so
this is how we did
did it
because if not sorry if you followed but
we had a problem where we couldn't get
the decimal by dividing by 10 had some
issues so then we created an array we
went over the exponent and we did the
multiplication
and whenever it was
over 10
we added to the next array as so forth
so at the end we basically had a big big
array with all the digits of this number
all right so something similar we have
to do here but
[Music]
and I guess here basically here we only
checked it's over ten so if it was then
we added one but now we also need to
keep track
oh we also need to keep track to see
because we could have something like
wait so if we have
let's see by factorial why what's the
process so we have 1 times 2 times 3
times 4 times 5 right
so the first one we have to then have
times 3 times 4 times 5 then we have 6
times 4 times 5 then we have 24 times 5
and then we have 120 now how this works
is that we need to multiply 5 by 4 and
then that's 20 put 0 saved 2 and then 5
plus x 2 and we add them up that's the
trick here
[Music]
not only that we need to multiply the
digit
by the number
oh but I think it's the same right array
that flanked yeah we multiplied by the
number
this will be our growing number instead
of just two
and over ten so we need to keep track
over 10 will be by default zero
let's try to do it here so array this
will start with one
we get n to be the
[Music]
not the exponent this time but what we
need to go over
we don't need this I don't need this
anymore let's cancel that lock this okay
so we get em and we want to go over
let's see I will be well let's start
with one and we go up to an inclusive
okay over ten will be to get next we go
over the latest length and the new value
will be array of J okay so the current
index get x this will be x pi and plus
over ten
this is values but our and array of I
will be new value get is it
okay if new value is bigger than nine
then array of J will be dead and over
ten will be met that floor array of J
divided by ten so if we have something
like 7 x 8 or let's make five times late
because it's easier 5 times 8 is 40 here
we're going to do 5 times 8 it's 40 we
don't have anything so it will remain 40
array of j will be 40 but it's bigger
than 9 so what we're going to do is to
get the 0 and then over 10 will be medic
floor divided so 40 divided by 10 which
is 4 right and this will be 0 by default
so if over 10 we push over Ted at the
end
and I think this would work I know
should it let's see we don't have that
zero yeah that's a start
[Laughter]
reduce
to having the ra0 good good good good
good good good good good
or a that went is one you're a Raj times
I plus zero your value should work but
not
if
ten push Oh
I know why oh let's see cancel that vlog
i okay it goes over everything
let's see J here zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero
that's not good why is that
council that plug new value
one two six 24 2000 zero zero zero
you
okay and cause of that flogged array
one two six twenty four okay so
something happens
[Music]
so when we have 24 the new value array
that J will be 4 over 10 will be that
number but we don't
let's see over 10 over 10 over 10 this
is the new value new
okay so the new value is 1 over 10 to 0
get over 1008 n is 0 get 24 over 10 is 0
no no no no no oh I see so we're
dividing the array that J to 10 again so
now we want to get a new value divided
by 10 so now we get yeah 4 + 2 4 NT
perfect let's see move the console logs
and see what we get
ray zero zero zero zero okay this looks
interesting
whoa look at this
to get
what's this
so I guess the reduce now it doesn't
work okay so something somewhere
then that is off
let's see we're checking the array again
all right so here what's happening
Oh
we're pushing over ten
I see so we're having big big numbers
and well big two-digit numbers
I is not on it won't be one digit
anymore it will be two digits and we're
multiplying the two digits with every
digit which is okay right so first it
will be I times 1 times 2 times 3 times
4 times 5 and so on and then we have
times 10 times 11 so then it might get
more than
ah
one digit and that's not good how we
solve this
here you can see so one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
11 12 13 14 15
you
it's here probably
you
at least is the met right
what I want to do is to see the array
and also I want to see the sum now I
want to array that reverse and that join
I just want to see the numbers so 1 2 6
24
three times four times five nope nope
nope not good why is that
you
Oh 18 reverses altering the array
now
bigint yeah probably probably that will
be our
a radar traversed like this
all right yeah so it was altering the
[Music]
the array okay so five then 120 times
six okay times 7 49 10 data yeah that
looks good times 8 is 40 times 9 or
times Anya times 10 times 11 so it looks
like let's see this times 11
okay times 12
okay times 13
times 14 so it looks okay but why why
did looks better so we are here let's
see if we get this times 15
1:03 seven
why we get 13 here quite two-digit
you
[Music]
sixteen
okay so the mat is still working
is it so
one eight nine eight eight eight zero
zero yeah seventeen
this number times 17 okay so we can see
okay sweet works why do we get these
digits here
something I don't understand
although the net is right maybe too many
carryovers yeah but why
[Laughter]
okay one approach
so if over ten we push over ten if you
wouldn't well we would have this
okay so then over ten
this needs to be fixed if over ten while
over 10 is bigger than 9
I want to raid that push man that floor
but no I want to push over 10 modulus 10
oh and ng sorry I can't see angle wit
welcome to being a sponsor supporter on
freaking camp thank you on their behalf
carryover should be divided by ten
modules ten as well
yeah over ten is 13 it is what I want to
do over ten then becomes method for over
ten divided by ten
ah right
so while that
if over 10 is different than zero we do
that
broken so a well over ten greater than
nine array that push
the digit
then over 10 becomes mad at floor over
10/10 so becomes the next digit
but it might
yeah I think we need another check here
if over 10 well it will be different
than zero now
we want to push it again radar push over
time okay
yeah
the issue was that we did the division
but then if the digit was different than
say well if it was something then we had
to push it again okay
good
good look at that
so now it works we only had to add this
thing well to basically split the list
but all right now it should work
hey it was good that we had the solution
so let me let me get this oceans I don't
want to waste them anymore alright
what's the time okay let's let's try to
do one more at least how many we did
like three right
oh boy they're getting harder and harder
Emme cable
numbers
that's right let deal van be defined as
the sum of proper divisors of n numbers
less than n which divide evenly into n
if d of a equals B and D of B equals a
were a different a B and a and B are an
amicable pair and each of a and B are
called amicable numbers
okay for example the proper divisors of
220 r12 for data therefore D of 220
is to 84
so yeah they're the some of the
divisions the divisor sorry is 284 the
proper divisors of 284 are 1 2 4 & 1 1
471 and 142 so that's that evaluate the
sum of all the amicable numbers under
end
okay now this is interesting
first we can I need to get the TV source
and then we need to add them up and then
check
some of the mmm eatable number is that
number so we need to get D of n well D
of X which will be a number Y and then
we need to check if do y equals to X
well they use the MB and if they are
we're going to add them to an array and
then we need to add find the sum of all
those
okay
I feel like there are a lot of
numbers here
I'm thinking
can we speed this up okay I guess we
need to go over all the numbers right so
find somewhere under n okay so we start
with one is one amicable number D of 1
is 1 deal
maybe
oh no because a and B are should be
different okay so one is not what about
two to week 2 now 3
as one in three is for forests
let's see so the visitors of three are
one and three which is four divisions of
four are
one and two which is three so these are
friends friendly numbers
okay what about two has one until which
is - which well - has one and two this
is an infinite loop but then a MB must
be different so we start with three okay
get up and I plus plus
[Music]
let's see we need a function to check if
is Fred boy I can't pronounce this name
sorry I just call it friendly if it's
friendly let me note friendly equals
amicable but sorry can't pronounce it
just so we have a note
good so if it's friendly I then we want
to have here comes friendly numbers will
be an array if it's friendly than
friendly numbers will push I a simple as
that now
how do we find if it's a friendly he is
friendly I first find all the divisors
so let the visors for let I Sardis let's
let's make this end I is 1 I less than
equals 2 + / - right
goes up to the number well up to the
half of the number I plus plus if and
modulus I is 0 then the Wizards at cush
I right so now we should have all the
divisors
giggity I think up to dirt
oh so many spaces and all that so we
start with that with increase with one
we check if it's feasible okay if it is
we push there now we need the some some
of the deserts will going to use reduce
accumulator item number and accumulator
plus number start with zero
we get the sum
get
get the sum of the divisors and now
[Music]
we kind of need to check if this is
friendly
you
well I guess now we need
today's numbers the resource add them up
and see if equals to this
okay let's make another function some of
the VCRs of that and this function will
do this
return this okay
good so find all the divisors
them up and now here some
that's the cast a will be some of sorry
yeah some of dave event right
and cost P let's see so we have the sum
of divisions this will be okay I think I
got got a bit messed up here so we have
the divisors of the first number and the
sum of them and now we need to see
if some of the visions of a
is be there a equals B is that friendly
number not defined where
friendly numbers
infinite loop why
where
so let's think again
a will be be so this will be a okay
let's do it like this B will be dev of a
and
a will be leave be
yeah and now but we're kind of resetting
this
believe is ours will be some divisions
will be and we need to check if
you know what let's do it like they have
a number here be will be this a will be
depth and we need to check if a2 equals
to B all right let's see console that
plug a and B here's right
I also want to see em which is the
number so three has
let me select this
some of the divisors of 3 is 1 and
they're the number now it doesn't count
okay so the number itself won't count so
we have 1 and then some of the visitors
of 1
well it's here oh I guess
yet
we have four four has one and two which
is three three has one okay five has
one and one and one has zero good six
has one and two and three which is six
things off I feel like I'm missing
something
which is six but we've done
and then yeah ace
B we can earn it here we messed up with
the naming conventions because here we
don't need check if AIDS well they
should be different than B
Cave
let's slow down so we have this number
right which is and we want to get some
of its division the deserts and the
visors okay
well be some of that get now this yeah
will be 294 which will be B
says here right D of a well the of the
number will be and then
we need to get a divisions of this one
and should be a
goes into a and if these are equal
that's good although
a and B should be different so an and B
okay let's go to 220 let's see what we
get there
220 is 284 and 284 is 220
so no
not a is P we need to check if a is
different than B
and an is equal to a
let's go now back
so this is n this is B and this is a
these two numbers should not be the same
but and should equal to a
to 84 we should see the same thing
happening yeah
and be is it different than a but then n
should be equal to 2ei okay good so this
is good and this returns true or false
if it's friendly we push and let's see
friendly numbers
line four
now it shouldn't mean infinite look
constant that vlog
we get these numbers
we need to add them up
oops something's wrong
for a thousand
we get it right
accumulator number cumulated pass number
zero so we get it right 4,000
you get to try for 2,000
or 5,000 we don't whoops
and neither for 10,000
maybe it's something with the let let's
just run and see
okay so apparently it works maybe this
console.log is broken yeah although this
is the brute-force approach and one
thing we could save would be here
well when we get the friendly number we
kind of know it's partner right so we
could stored both of them so then for
example when we had 220 and 284 we
already knew that 220 by checking here
he is a friendly number we could also
added 284 so then when we get to 284 we
don't do the calculation again but it
works so it's good what every developer
says I guess
okay let's save this and then for today
I don't think we have time for another
one let's look over it and
[Music]
see what is it the part using names and
already defined in the background
containing over five tiles and first
names big begin by sorting it into
alphabetical order then working out of
the political value for each name
multiply these vela bytes of a
particular position in the list obtain a
name score for example when the list is
sorted alphabetically order calling
which is worth three plus okay
he's the 303 938 name in the list so
calling will obtain a score of this
what's the total of all the name scores
in the array
okay this shouldn't be that hard so
let's do it basically we need to get
well let's see using names an array demo
okay
begin by sorting it so first to sort it
so I write at sort
okay so first we sort it a is only test
this this is only a test then
to convert the strings into the sum of
the characters
so function some of characters will get
a string and here
cuz some is 0 for let I 0 I less than
swing that length I plus plus and what
we want here you want to use the SG
table and we want to convert capital C
to 3 so we need to
Capital c67 we need to well subtract 64
right yeah so a minus 64 is 165 - is for
you one yeah so 64 is our number we want
to get the character value so
string.fromcharcode string of I minus 64
this will be added to the sum and we'll
return the sum yet now this will add to
some of the characters if we go over
this and your sum of characters we
should
oops this would be let not the number
not now perfect that's what we want
what's happening here spring from
charcoal
oops sorry now this is the wrong
function we need to do chart code that I
good so he now becomes well let me where
is it yes console dot log array so we
have a is 1 is 28 and so on and so forth
and while we do the map sum of
characters and then we want to another
map to multiply with index so number and
index this will be number times index
plus 1 right for example when this is
sorted calling is word like that is the
1938 in done list so we get the index
times the score and we get a number yet
so we map over we get a number we get
the index then we multiply the number
with index
all right good and at the end we need to
add up this thingy so we can use the
reduce again we get a number we go sorry
we get accumulator the number and we add
it to the accumulator stop picture and
look at that then
it worked I was afraid but it worked
well you're always afraid with these
kind of challenges
good so with a bit of help from the Rae
methods using the chair to that then
doing some conversions we are done and
we did another one let's submit this
and we're going to have this one be the
next one for probably next week I hope
you enjoy this I'm sorry at the
beginning it was harder we well we buy
we I mean I I kind of messed it up but
indeed it was farther I think it was the
hardest problem we had so far this one
thanks to Laurent for helping and also
thanks to doc for helping we solved it
okay
Lauren said that they think using the
date function is a bit cheating for for
one of the problems oh wow but
you
thank your for watching I hope you
enjoyed it if you did give it a like and
subscribe to the flicker camp YouTube
channel if you haven't already thank you
for watching and I wish I wish which a
good day bye